hey guys pete here today i'm going to go
over the timeline for one of my favorite
shows
dark on netflix in dark everything is
connected and since time travel is a
thing we move through multiple timelines
which can make following what's
happening when
very complicated this two-part video
will cover everything we've seen through
seasons one and two so far
and if you haven't watched the second
season yet it will contain massive
spoilers
with that out of the way let's jump
right in because there's a lot to cover
the oldest thing we've seen in dark so
far is the photo of the group
sikh mundus creatus s which we know was
taken on january 8
1921 according to the back of the photo
it shows adam older noah adult agnes
nielsen
and older magnus nielsen which have all
been named so far
on screen also it has who we presume are
older franziska
and older bartosz to either side of
magnus which haven't been named but we
know they all travel together
with the stranger aged jonas at the end
of season two
there are six more unidentified people
in the photo
one of them could be erna but beyond
that we don't know who they
are and there's a lot of speculation but
we won't really know until we know
before i get into the rest of this i
just want to say as a native english
speaker i'm going to murder
the pronunciations of all of these names
i read through the show as subtitles
every name is pronounced as a german
speaker would say it since i'm not that
the way i read it and the way it sounds
can be two different things
the first date we actually see is june
21 1921
on that day we meet young noah with the
character who
is possibly older bhartov they're
digging the passage in the caves and
then we see
noah kill the other man because he has
lost faith
on the same day we see adam order older
noah to find the missing pages of the
notebook
on june 23rd of that year two days later
young jonas arrives from
2053. he's taken to ernest house
which is like a boarding house and meets
young agnes
and young noah on june 24th older noah
lies to adam about finding the pages
from the notebook
young jonas wakes up at erna's and goes
to the caves only to find that they
aren't completed yet
young noah tells him they won't be
completed for 32 more years
back at the church later both noah's
take him to meet adam who explains that
he
is actually the older version of jonah
on june 25th 1921 the next day
jonas talks with adam again adam
explains that the group sick mundus is
fighting a war against god which is time
itself
adam shows young jonas the machine that
they have built in the 1921 timeline
and explains that it can transport him
to the exact day he needs to get to
the day before his father commits
suicide we see jonas leave for
2019 then later in that same day we see
that adam has the saint christopher
medallion
and older magnus asked why he didn't
tell young jonas the truth about his
role in their plan
two days later on june 27th we see older
noah talking to his younger self
about why he needs to travel and then we
see younger noah leave for 2020.
older noah shows at him that he did find
the missing notebook pages
and accuses him of lying to him and
using him he tries to
kill adam but he can't then agnes his
sister
arrives and kills older noah instead
after that the older magnus
and presumed older franziska send adam
to 2020 through the machine
that marks the end of what we've seen in
the 1921 period
the next year we spend time in is 1953.
on november 5th eric's dead body arrives
in the bunker after being sent there
through the chair from 1986
the middle age or the adult aged helga
removes the body four days later on
november 9th
he removes yasen's body that ended up
there as well
the day after that on november 10th the
two boys bodies are discovered at the
construction site for the nuclear plant
this is the same day that adult ulric
travels from 2019
he sees agnes and young toronto as they
are moving to wynden
we see them arrive at the tidmons to
rent a room
later gretchen young claudia's dog
disappears into the caves
ulrich visits townhouse's shop and
leaves his jacket and phone there
he overhears that there have been two
bodies found at the construction site
he goes and finds younger helga and
tries to kill him
leaving what he thinks is his dead body
behind in the bunker
the next day november 11th ulrich is
arrested by
egon tiedermann and he does that because
he thinks he killed the two boys
young helga wakes up inside the bunker
older claudia visits
younger hg tan house telling him to
build the time machine so things can be
set straight
the following day november 12th younger
helga sees the time portal open
and travels to 1986 through it this is
the last thing
we see in 1953.
after that there are a few days we spend
in 1954.
on june 22nd older claudia buries the
time machine so that her younger self
will be able to find it later
the next day on june 23rd younger helga
returns to the doppler family home
he doesn't speak to his mother so later
she asks older noah to help
he asks helga to read a passage and he
does
younger claudia walks in on her mother
doris and agnes together
and later asked younger tronta to pull
down his pants for her
older claudia gives agnes a newspaper
article that talks about her murder and
tells her to go to older noah
agnes tells him that older claudia has
the missing notebook pages and tells him
to ask adam if she can rejoin sick
mundus
aegon goes to visit ulrich in his cell
because helga has returned home and then
he gets a visit from older claudia who
apologizes to him in his office he
doesn't understand who she is and why
she's
there older claudia then visits younger
10 house
gives him his book a journey through
time and tells him that he will have to
explain the time machine to her one day
later older noah finds older claudia and
kills her after she tells him that
everything
adam tells him is a lie he recovers the
missing pages from the triquetra
notebook pages from her and is clearly
upset by what they say
we don't see what they contain but
there's something about his daughter
charlotte in them
and we see that he's upset three days
later on june 26th
aegon looks at older claudia's body
thinking that she is probably oryx
accomplice in halga's kidnapping
he goes to ask younger helga about her
and he hears the term white devil
later that same day hannah arrives from
2020.
she goes looking for ulrich and that has
her cross paths with egon
they go to the psychiatric hospital
where she ultimately decides to leave
ulrich because she thinks he still
favors katarina
and her family over her after seeing him
she appears to decide
to stay in 1954 and there's also a hint
of her coming on to aegon and his office
from there we leave the 1950s and head
to 1986.
some of the things we learned about in
1986 we don't
know exactly what day they happen
because we see them in flashbacks
for example we learned that toronto and
claudia have been having an affair
we know that at some point older noah
arrives to become the new priest
and that sometime during the summer the
power plant has an accident
on october 9th the adult helga kidnaps
mads nielsen
nearly a month later on november 4th
helga travels to 2019 through the cave
on the same day mads is sent to 2019
using the chair but it kills him and he
arrives dead
the next day november 5th mikkel arrives
from 2019 through the cave he ends up in
the hospital after looking for his
family
aegon investigates 33 dead sheep
charlotte finds a dead bird older byrne
shows claudia the hidden radioactive
waste as she is about to take over his
position running the power plant
helga gives her a copy of a journey
through time as a present for her new
position
and we see the author tanhaus working on
the time machine
in his shop on the same day eric is sent
to 1953
using the chair but he doesn't survive
the journey
either on november 7th teenage ulrich is
arrested because hannah made the false
claim that he raped katarina
to the police stranger age jonas arrives
from 2019 to talk
to tanhaus about time and fixing the
time machine
the next day november 8th younger jonas
arrives
from 2019 through the cave on november
9th
younger jonas goes back to 2019 without
bringing
mickel with him on that same day we see
mikkel
and young hannah meet each other at the
hospital
and that's also the same day that jason
is transported to 1953
by using the chair and of course he also
dies in that process
two days later on november 11th boris
kneewald arrives in winden
and takes on the identity of alexander
kohler
as he's running away from possibly
committing to murders in marburg
younger hannah sees him dispose of the
real passport
and his gun she goes and takes those and
keeps them
and holds on to them throughout the rest
of the timeline
younger hannah also tells younger
katarina
that she thinks that regina was probably
the false witness for the rape which
katarina
takes on to be the truth because there's
no evidence the younger ulrich is
released from prison
we see him reunited with katarina we see
them
causing problems for regina and then
younger alexander
comes into her rescue on that same day
we see claudia find
gretchen they're reunited and gretchen
had just arrived from 1953.
helga goes to older noah he doesn't want
to continue with murdering people
but at the same time he doesn't leave at
the cabin
we see him hide from aegon older aegon
who's coming there to interview him on
november 12th
claudia hires younger alexander
to work at the power plant he welds the
door between the power plant and the
cave shut
stranger jonas returns to tan house's
shop and picks up the finished time
machine
older helga confronts his younger self
and asks him to stop working for older
noah
but helga doesn't listen to himself enos
adopts
mikkel younger jonas arrives again to
save
mikel and bring him back but he ends up
getting kidnapped
by helga and older noah we see
the older jonas the stranger aged one
visit
his younger self in the bunker and tell
him who he is
tells him he's the older version of
himself and explains why he can't let
him out of the bunker
that night older helga tries to kill his
younger self
in a car accident but his younger self
lives and
the older version dies stranger jonas
attempts to destroy the wormhole but
only closes the passage in the caves
at that point the time portal opens over
windon
younger helga and jonas touch each
other's hands through it
and that brings younger helga to 1986
and sends younger jonas to 2052.
in 1987 on june 22nd older claudia
visits
her younger self at her office at the
power plant and tells her who she
is she shows her the time machine and
the caves and tell her that she has to
stop
adam we see older noah and
mickel meet outside of the caves older
egon
visits helga and the psychiatric
hospital
and he asked him about mad's
disappearance why he didn't show up for
the interview
he also visits older ulrich in the psych
ward for the first time
but he doesn't have any idea of who he
is
hannah and jonas arrive they travel with
the machine
and they see innocent mickle together at
the house
and later on that same day claudia digs
up the time machine that her
older version had buried for her in her
yard
on the next day june 23rd older noah
successfully transports younger helga
back to 1953 using the chair
claudia goes to visit helga and ask him
why he gave her the book a journey
through time
he tells her to never trust noah older
egon goes back
to visit ulrich but at this time
he tells him that he is actually ulrich
nielsen
claudia goes and visits tanhaus who
explains the bootstrap paradox
explains how his book traveled to him
from the future before he wrote it older
egan
tries to go and talk to mikkel about his
parents
but innis won't let him talk to him egon
then goes to
visit claudia at her office and tells
her about his cancer
after that he returns with mickel's
photo
and shows that to ulrich and ulrich
attacks him in the process claudia
travels to 2020
using the machine and then returns back
on the same day
the next day on june 25th claudia asks
her father to move in with them she's
trying to avoid his death
she meets with bernd he gives her the
information about the god particle
she takes a sample of that and gives it
to a tech to have him
analyze it we see inna's at the hospital
stealing
medication that she's using to drug
mikkel
old ulric breaks out of the hospital and
he goes
and meets with mikkel tries to take him
to the cave
in hopes of taking him back to 2020.
innis ends up calling older egon and
asks for help older egon and the police
end up stopping ulrich from being able
to take mikkel
through the caves and they arrest him
again and take him back to the
psychiatric hospital
magnus franziska martha and bartos
with younger elizabeth all arrive from
2020 from the back of the police car
old orrick sees them by the bus stop but
he's unable to talk to them
and then later that same day they all
return to 2020.
on june 26 claudia starts to record
herself discussing what she's learned
about the development at the plant with
the god particle
she ends up going to aegon's first chemo
session with him
and he tells her what he's starting to
realize that time travel is real
he explains what's going on with ulrich
and mickel and the caves
he wants to act on this information he
wants to call the police
claudia tries to get him to stop talking
about it
they end up having an argument he falls
hits his head
claudia is about to call the paramedics
but she decides
not to change anything thinking that she
needs to make this sacrifice
because that's the way things are
supposed to go and that this will
ultimately
save regina younger jonas
after spending what is about a year
learning from
older claudia arrives at claudia's house
and says that she has to come with him
immediately
on the next day june 27th we see younger
jonas
and claudia they go to the caves they
get a sample of
the waist younger jonas and claudia then
use the time machine to reopen the
passage
and they leave together for 2020
so that's roughly half of the timeline
i'm gonna stop there right after i
finish this editing putting it together
then i'll do a part two that has
everything else in the timeline
let me know in the comments if i have
anything out of place i tried to
put everything together but sometimes
it's confusing considering
everything that's going on let me know
what you think of dark in general what
do you think's gonna happen
in season three and be sure to like this
video
subscribe to my channel come back to
check part two
and thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon
you